( intro music )
( transition music )
( applause )
Asher: So I want to start
with two questions.
How do you connect to the wild,
and when do you
connect to the wild?
My relationship with the wild
began as a child
with something as simple
as a smile.
The smile that you see
on my face right now
is not the one that
I had as a kid.
Where you see incisors,
I once had fangs.
This led me to
believe I was a bat.
I would run about
the house with a cape
tied to my neck and my hands
pretending I could fly.
I'm sorry to say that
I never took off.
One of the many
disappointments of childhood,
things that you learn
your limitations.
Few years later,
I remember reading this article
about fruit bats,
and a large number of them
are being consumed
by the thousands in Guam,
and being shipped from
the Pacific Islands to Guam.
This is a commercial outfit.
To think that somebody
would want to consume
something that I had
been not too long ago,
was kind of shocking.
( laughter )
It really did not
resonate with me,
and I figured I needed
to do something about that
at some point in my life.
But I didn't think to start
then, which I should have,
and I'm always amazed
by people who start early
because it's never
too early to start.
If you're reacting to something,
do something right
then and there.
Don't wait for tomorrow,
don't wait for another day,
don't wait to become something.
You're already everything
you need to be to act.
Anyhow, so going forward,
eventually I found my way
back into conservation
which I'm really grateful for,
and I wound up dealing
with numerous species
through numerous
non-profit outfits.
For me wild is
an implicit part of who I am,
and how I function daily.
It is part of our biological
and evolutionary development,
it is a part of our lineage,
it's where we come from.
It is our past,
it is in our present,
and it should jolly well
be a part of our future,
and that is why I do what I do
because it is so important to me
to evoke this connection
that I feel on a cellular level
in every individual
I encounter every day.
It led me to dealing with
ivory and rhino horn,
and all of last year went by
just tackling this one issue,
and trying to tell the same
story over and over again
in as many ways as possible.
These were campaigns
for Elephant Voices,
Joyce Poole's organization,
dealing with poaching
in Kenya.
This particular
campaign was supposed to
cast a light on what's happening
with the Chinese consumer market
being the largest stakeholder
in this game.
It is a numbers game.
It is about tipping points,
money and time.
And time is running out
at the cost of these animals.
This particular campaign shows
these two Chinese characters
which spells China in Chinese,
Zhongguo ,
and beneath that I've written
"Stop the trade.
Every toss costs a life."
This got Joyce thrown out
of a TCM Conference,
Traditional Chinese
Medicine Conference,
and she called me panicked,
being,
"Oh my gosh, I can't believe
it had such a huge outcry
that I had to be basically
evicted from the premises."
She said, "I don't know
whether this was a good thing,"
but after a lot of debate
we realized it was a good thing
because shortly after,
we started getting e-mails
with images like this.
This was the less
shocking image.
I got e-mails with people
who had tattooed this
onto their backs and arms.
I was surprised that
a single artwork that I created
could have such deep
impact on people's lives
that they felt like it
could extend their voice
and empower who they were
and what they stood for
in the world.
We started running these
campaigns as open source.
Anybody could print them out
and use them any which way
they felt was appropriate
to get the story out there.
There were demonstrations
completely decentralized,
organized by students, schools,
and non-profits
around the world,
all carrying banners.
There were banners
hanging outside people's houses,
as bumper stickers in cars.
I would get images
daily sent in,
and it was really quite
lovely to see
that these images could really
have such a strong reach
across the world.
Which led me to finding
ways to communicate
the same story in as
many media as possible,
as well as to tell every
angle of the story.
So this is to cast a light
on the terror attacks
and the trade in firearms
because illicit contraband
does contribute to that.
It's almost important to educate
the Chinese demographic
about how each tusk
or rhino horn costs a life;
it does result in death.
Most Chinese people
believe that
the elephant tusk is like
a tooth, it just falls out
and it's picked up by somebody
and delivered to
the marketplace.
I needed to show this in a way,
in places where loads
of eyes would have
access to these images.
We ran these on mass
transport systems in China,
as well as
on consumer magazines
in partnership with WildAid,
African Wildlife Foundation,
and Save Our Elephants.
Because we want to target people
who had the purchasing power,
who could have immediate impact
on what was happening
on the fields.
Because when you
kill the demand,
when you stop the buying,
it stops the killing.
It's not just important
to educate people
about what's happening,
but also to cast light
on cultural consciousness
and shift perspectives
that are held
for extended periods of
time and get those people
to extend the empathy
that they feel toward one thing
toward the other thing.
Moving from the known
to the unknown.
These two campaigns
which were run across China
in a similar format
on mass transport,
as well as on billboards
and magazines,
were to help the Chinese
extend this pride that they feel
in the conservation success
that they've achieved
with pandas in China
to African wildlife
hence "The pandas of Africa."
It was run in a vocabulary
they understood,
and it went viral in China
which was a tremendous success
because it was tweeted on Weibo
and in all
the local social media.
The Chinese adopted it
as their own message
because it was
not targeting them
and singling them out.
Instead it was showing them,
"You've done something well,
extend that positive attitude
towards something else."
For me, I'm haunted
by this crisis.
My dating life is kind of
ruined by it because...
( laughter )
...frankly when I go out
on a date with a stranger,
I'm thinking all the while
about the one
that's lost every
fifteen minutes.
By the time we get
to dessert I'm like,
"Is this guy worth
six elephants?"
( laughter )
When you're weighing
it like that,
it's very hard to sit through
that evening.
( laughter )
It also ends up affecting
me during my sleep cycle,
it ruins my REM
cycle continually.
Or sometimes I actually end up
strategizing solutions
and taking notes.
I always sleep with
an iPhone by my bed,
or a notebook
because I never know
when a sketch is
going to occur to me.
Not to mention bathroom breaks.
If I wake up in the
middle of the night,
and this was one
particular situation,
is a sequence that actually
unfolded one evening.
I woke up at three
in the morning,
I went to the loo, sat down,
and as I'm peeing I'm
looking out the door,
and I see a tile on the floor -
tree rings in this wooden tile.
And I'm immediately thinking
about geological time
and about the Giant Sequoia
that I first encountered
as a child
in the British Natural
History Museum.
About how these species
encompass our stories
and assimilate us in
such a profound way.
This particular sequoia ring
started out its life in 557.
From there, moving forward,
it has assimilated
the rise of Islam,
spread of Christianity,
it has seen so much down
to the birth and
death of Gandhi.
When we cut a tree
like that down,
we're cutting this huge
part of our history down.
So when a species goes extinct
it's not just about
that one individual species
that's going off our radar,
but about the fact that
this huge part of our story
has just gone missing.
And that is
such a terrible loss to me.
Immediately I got to the desk,
didn't go back to bed,
started sketching out a rhino,
juxtaposing this
tree ring into it,
and then trying to
find ways in which
I can show how time
is lapsing for the species.
The primary horn
became a sand timer,
but a blood timer so
every drop that falls
is adding to that
narrative of loss.
The secondary horn
is a metronome
with a AK-47 going back
and forth, keeping count.
The eye of the rhino
has a clock
that reads a second before
midnight because if you
compress geological time
into twenty four hours,
we came onto this planet
a second before midnight,
and we've had this
immense amount of impact,
changed the face of this
planet within that second.
How do I extend
the same narrative
on to yet other ideas?
This was about elephants,
hence burning of the ivory,
the stockpiles.
Thinking about how
that connects to China.
Incense clocks were
what they used back in the day,
so burning of incense.
Then thinking about
how the target
swings back and forth
just waiting for them
to be culled down.
Moving that forward, how can we
evolve this into a solution
that's about having a rise
in our energy consciousness?
Not just moving to
new energy economies,
but also finding this deeper,
spiritual connection to nature
to see if we have the capacity
to re-wild ourselves.
Despite being disconnected,
despite living
in the cities that we live in,
if there is an honest way
in which we understand
that the rhino is a part
of who we are,
that the elephant is
a part of who we are,
and we cannot live without
them in this world with us.
This particular campaign
I ran in New York
to raise funding.
It was crowd sourced,
so every time a donor
contributed
to this particular campaign,
I would replace
a graphically illustrated hand
with an actual human hand.
When I finished raising funding,
I had all the human
hands up there,
and this is the power
of us coming together.
All of this resulted in me
getting a billboard up
in Times Square, on Broadway,
between 46 and 47th,
in partnership with loudSource,
and March for Elephants,
for a month.
It ran twenty four seven,
and I'm going to play
the spot for you.
( gunshot )
( groaning elephant )
( gunshots )
( tapping )
( elephant groaning )
( applause )
Asher: The acousticscape
for this particular animation
was acquired from
Elephant Listening Project,
Katy Payne's work.
This was an actual recording
of a poaching incident in Gabon.
You hear the shots being
fired in the beginning,
the elephants groaning,
succumbing to those shots,
and then you hear the poachers
hacking into their faces,
and the sound of that ...
( tapping )
that's the axe hitting against
the bone and also the tusk.
You hear them
groaning even after.
That's because they're alive
and conscious for this.
You actually see
elephants in Africa
stumbling about with
completely caved in faces
because they've eaten in
with an ax,
and it's still alive.
You have to wait for
that elephant to fall
before you can even handle
what's happening with it.
It's a pretty grisly trade.
It's really brutal and bloody.
Oh, by the way, that
particular campaign
got over 1.5 million views.
That's 1.5 million
eyes that were reached,
minds that were reached
and hopefully changed
in some way by that campaign.
I did have a lot of
people come up to me
and ask me what ivory was
which was a little shocking.
It's the world we live in,
so the need to educate,
I cannot underscore that enough.
If you know,
transmit that knowledge.
It has to happen now,
use social media.
I mean taking a selfie is not
just about who we are today,
but who we are has that power.
Becoming that selfie
means that you have
a stand in this world, you
have a place in this world,
and therefore you need
to speak up through it.
Use yourself as a vessel.
Moving forward,
it's not just about
the megafauna that is going
extinct because of our actions.
It's also the habitat
lost that's resulting
in compromised living situations
for all of these
incredible animals.
This particular campaign
was illustrated in charcoal
because the charcoal trade,
I don't know how many of you
know about this,
is pretty rampant
in African countries.
They fell over 400,000
acres in just Tanzania
to produce charcoal
because it's the main
energy source
for most Tanzanian households.
That's how they
light their stoves.
Because most
Tanzanian households,
the majority of the population
lives off grid.
This basically results in
loss of habitat
for the African wildlife.
Cheetahs that are basically
disintegrating before
our very own eyes.
These animals need
a lot of space.
They need the acres
to survive.
I was also in the
Serengeti recently
working with Frankfurt
Zoological Society very closely.
I got the opportunity
to talk to poachers,
from the poachers,
and also install this mural
in the Frankfurt office
in Seronera.
The mural actually speaks to
how I embed data
into a particular artwork.
Because the composition
was not just about
creating something beautiful,
but about how much information
I can embed in a given layout.
In this particular case,
I wanted to show the Serengeti
highway coming up.
I wanted to cast a light
on demographic momentum
in the upcoming years.
Because if you look
at the skyline
that I've illustrated,
you can actually see
from 12 million the population
when it peaks at Empire State,
is going to be at 200 million
just in Tanzania.
Where is this
population going to go?
How is infrastructure going to
develop in the coming years?
How are we going to stop
the wild from getting
infringed, fenced in,
and fragmented
like it has everywhere
else in the world?
These are the questions
I wake up to every day.
The reason why I do
campaign after campaign,
image after image,
day in and day out,
is because I want to change
the one thing that I know
will have the most impact
in the world around me.
And that's you.
Thank you.
( applause )
( outro music )